das ist wirklich eine sensationelle
entdeckung die eine chinesische
australisches forschungsteam da gemacht
hat denn obwohl die milchstraße ja quasi
unsere kosmische heimat ist wissen wir
längst noch nicht alles über sie doch
durch die positionsbestimmung von
hunderten speziellen sternen haben
fachleute jetzt eine dreidimensionale
karte der milchstraße erstellt und die
enthüllt eine wirklich spannende
besonderheit unserer galaxie klicks um
science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierend des
seins videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
dieses thema ist wirklich besonders
spektakulär und es kommt von euch aus
dem klick zum desktop server vielen dank
dafür
konkret geht es um die milchstraße von
der forschungsteams weltweit bisher
angenommen hatten dass sie relativ flach
ist bis auf die ausbuchtung in der mitte
da hatten wir ja darüber berichtet sie
stammt von der kollission mit einer
anderen galaxie die jetzt teil unserer
milchstraße ist und schließlich erinnern
auch andere spiralgalaxien wie andromeda
beispielsweise an eine scheibe und das
ist ganz easy durch ein teleskop zu
sehen anders dagegen bei der milchstraße
sie ist eine besonderheit und ihre form
ist nicht so einfach zu bestimmen
das liegt ganz einfach an unserer
position schließlich ist die erde ein
teil von ihr und befindet sich mitten in
dieser sternen ansammeln und die
milchstraße als ganzes zu sehen macht
das unmöglich doch seit einiger zeit
gibt es hinweise darauf dass die
milchstraße vor allem in ihrem äußeren
bereich gar nicht so flach sein könnte
wie die fachleute es bisher angenommen
hatten
doch wie soll man das herausbekommen ein
internationales forschungsteam bediente
sich jetzt eines tricks und bestimmte
zunächst die genauen positionen von 1339
speziellen sternen konkret ging es dabei
um junge massereiche sterne die zur
gruppe der käfigen gehören das besondere
an diesen sogenannten kosmischen
meilenstein sie leuchten bis zu 100.000
mal heller als unsere sonne
die helligkeit dieser sterne die die
fachleute als positionsanzeige nutzen
unterliegt einem schwankungsrückstellung
des taktes von der leuchtkraft des
jeweiligen sterns ab
kann nicht nur relativ easy die absolute
helligkeit des sterns bestimmt werden
sondern auch seine entfernung zur erde
auch die exakte position am himmel ist
bekannt und somit gelang es den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern dann eine
dreidimensionale karte zu erstellen und
diese lüftet das bislang verborgene
geheimnis bei der milchstraße handelt es
sich um eine ganz besondere
spiralgalaxien sie ist alles andere als
eben sondern deutlich verformt quasi
tatsächlich krumm und schief auch wenn
die sternen und gas scheibe der
milchstraße relativ deckungsgleich sind
zeigt die 3d karte dass beide auffällig
verbogen sind dabei weichen die äußeren
regionen unserer milchstraße von der
haupt ebene der sternen scheibe auf der
einen seite nach oben und auf der
anderen seite nach unten bogenförmig ab
schaut man sich die milchstraße in
diesem modell von der seite an
ist sie leicht s förmig dazu der
australische forscher richard der gries
in den äußeren regionen der galaxie
haben mir zudem festgestellt dass die s
förmige sterne scheibe in einem
zunehmend verbogenen spiral muster
verformt ist die form unserer
milchstraße ist damit ziemlich selten
allerdings nicht einzigartig denn solch
eine verzogene und vertrete spirale war
auch schon bei anderen galaxien
beobachtet worden und genau diese
beobachtungen liefern auch hinweise auf
die ursache der verformung nach ansicht
des forschungsteam könnte sie durch
einen drehmoment der rotierenden
massereichen inneren sternen scheibe der
milchstraße begründet sein fest steht
jedenfalls die erkenntnisse zur form der
milchstraße könnten die grundlage legen
die geschichte der milchstraße weiter zu
entschlüsseln
zudem könnte dieses forschungsergebnis
auch bei weiteren ungeklärten
fragestellung helfen dazu ließ sein
denken einer der beteiligten forscher
diese ergebnisse liefern uns eine neue
taten grundlage für die erforschung der
stellaren bewegung in der galaxie denn
klar ist mit einer vorstellung davon wie
die milchstraße aussieht ist es sehr
viel einfacher entfernung von der sonne
in die außenbereiche der galaxie zu
bestimmen danke auf jeden fall für
diesen spektakulären themenvorschlag zum
desktop server kommt ihr über unseren
whatsapp newsletter dafür hier klicken
in der begrüßungs nachricht ist der link
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran